[Musique]
un combattant doté d'une combinaison
ultra-sophistiquée intégrant un
exosquelette et coiffé d'un casque à
réalité augmentée
il ne s'agit pas de science-fiction mais
peut-être de la physionomie du
combattant du futur
réalité augmentée intelligence
artificielle hyper connectivité
robotique l'explosion de nouvelles
technologies ne cesse de révolutionner
l'équipement du soldat et la manière
dont il se déplace décide et communique
alors à quoi ressemblera le combattant
dans une dizaine d'années
s'orientons vers un champ de bataille
4.0 peuplée de soldats augmenté et de
robots militaires autonomes
pour préparer nos armées au défi de
demain la loi de programmation militaire
2019-2025 a fait de l'innovation une
priorité
passant de 730 millions d'euros en 2018
à 1 milliard d'euros dès 2022
le journal de la défense vous propose de
découvrir ces innovations qui prend le
combattant du futur
les conflits d'aujourd'hui sont en
perpétuelle évolution
au Sahel comment le vent nous force ne
mène plus des guerres conventionnelles
anticiper les nouveaux besoins et donc
une nécessité opérationnelle et
stratégique mais à quoi ressembleront
les conflits de demain
pour répondre à cette question direction
l'état-major des armées à Paris où nous
retrouvons l'un des hauts responsables
de la préparation des capacités
militaires de demain
aucune guerre ne ressemble aux guerres
que l'on a connu et tout le travail que
l'on fait aujourd'hui dans les armées
c'est de se préparer à l'ensemble des
possibles et donc d'avoir une très
grande agilité pour faire face à tous
ces scénarios on doit apporter au
combattant qu'il soit soldat marin
aviateur tous les éléments qui lui
permettront de conserver l'initiative et
de gagner demain une bataille qui va
être très difficile donc la technologie
est un outil que l'on essaye
d'apprivoiser au mieux et d'adapter à ce
combattant aux conditions dans lequel
ils veulent l'employer
pour offrir les meilleurs outils à nos
forces l'état-major des armées
travaillent étroitement avec la
Direction générale de l'armement
nous collaboration qui vient de
connaître une nouvelle impulsion depuis
la parution de l'instruction
ministérielle sur la conduite des
opérations d'armement nous avons un
fonctionnement beaucoup plus intégré
entre la Direction générale de
l'armement et l'état-major des armées
puisque désormais nous prenons une
approche globale pour préparer
les systèmes futurs à l'échelle des
capacités par exemple le combat
érotérestre plutôt que programme par
programme est-ce que jusque là c'est
clair nous disposons désormais d'un lieu
dédié ici même à Balard donc un plateau
de travail collaboratif qui nous permet
de rapprocher vraiment les deux entités
alors on essaie d'analyser
toutes les évolutions technologiques
dans dans le civil et on mène un certain
nombre d'études amont pour vraiment
favoriser la montée en maturité des
différentes technologies ce qui nous
permet de vraiment bien les connaître
cette approche globale nous permet
d'ouvrir le champ des possibles
d'intégrer les innovations au plus tôt
et puis aussi de trouver des solutions
plus optimisées pour la définition des
systèmes le tout est basé sur des
modélisations des simulations sur la
base également de scénarios
opérationnels de missions dans l'exemple
du fantassin tout ce travail va nous
permettre par exemple de voir comment
intégrer au mieux les robots au sein des
différents échelons hiérarchiques donc
quel robot de tel type et en quelle
quantité il faudra placer au sein des
groupes des sections des compagnies et
puis ça permettra également d'analyser
comment le fantassin du futur pourra
être intégré au sein de la Force aéro
terrestre pour ce coordonner au mieux
avec les véhicules et avec les robots
face à la réalité des conflits à
l'urgence opérationnelle l'armée de
terre renouvelle régulièrement les
capacités de ses forces
baptiser scorpion son programme de
modernisation visa accélérer l'arrivée
de nouveaux équipements embarquant les
dernières innovations technologiques
des outils plus performants offrant une
meilleure protection au fantassin
à un homme un homme auquel on aura
amélioré les performances en terme
d'agression donc avec un fusil qui
tirera plus juste qui aura plus
facilement les cibles aussi bien de jour
que de nuit notamment grâce à la fusion
de capteurs de données on aura on va
faire évoluer sa protection avec une
protection balistique plus performante
plus légère de façon à ce que sa
mobilité elle également soit accrue de
façon à lui permettre d'être plus agile
sur le sur le champ de bataille on va
également augmenter sa connectivité de
façon à ce qu'il soit plus au fait de
son environnement situation ami
situation ennemie et l'appréhension
également de l'environnement physique
qui sera autour de lui
et ensuite au fur et à mesure de
l'évolution technologique on va
implémenter de plus en plus de
d'évolution en intégrant plus
d'intelligence artificielle de la
réalité augmentée une radio ultra
portative et puis lui adjoindre de la
robotique aussi bien robotique au sol le
robotique près du sol
[Musique]
50 vérifier la caméra d'hydrogène voir
si elle est bien serrée
[Musique]
pour sa mobilité également on va lui
adjoindre un exosquelette de façon à ce
qu'il puisse porter des charges lourdes
dans la durée en limitant ses efforts
physiques
[Musique]
innover et imaginez le combattant du
futur c'est la mission de l'Agence de
l'innovation de défense
cette agence oriente et coordonne les
projets les plus ambitieux
le combattant du futur en fait c'est
d'abord quelqu'un qui est connecté
évidemment qui est mieux équipé donc on
va travailler sur les textiles
fonctionnalisés par exemple ça veut dire
des combinaisons qui sont capables de
décontaminer ou qui sont capables de
d'auto réparer des blessures
superficielles on va travailler sur les
capteurs qui ne va porter
on travaille par exemple sur des projets
qui ont pour but de conférer des
capacités de vision nocturnes améliorées
en couleur on travaille également à
regarder ce qui se fait dans le monde de
l'optique avec des lentilles de contact
par exemple et ça sera incompétent qui
sera protégé et donc nous avons
plusieurs innovations en cours
aujourd'hui par exemple sur la
protection par rapport au bruit
traumatisant ou la protection par
rapport au choc qui sont en cours de en
cours de test et d'analyse par par
l'agence mais également dans sa mobilité
il sera assisté peut-être par un
exosquelette il sera assisté dans une
bulle par des robots et surtout il faut
pas s'arrêter simplement à son
équipement c'est à dire que le
combattant du futur il va être mieux
formés mieux entraîné donc on travaille
aussi sur toutes les stratégies
permettant d'optimiser la formation et
l'entraînement par l'intelligence
artificielle par la réalité virtuelle
par la réalité augmentée par exemple et
puis on travaille aussi sur sa
physiologie parce qu'il y a des études
qui que nous sommes en train de soutenir
sur l'adaptation physiologique dans des
milieux extrêmement contraignants
extrêmement difficiles et sur lequel il
y a aussi des innovations à trouver et
puis ça sera sans doute aussi l'amour
réparer c'est à dire des capacités qu'il
va emporter avec lui sur le théâtre des
opérations et qui lui permettront par
exemple de guérir d'une brûlure de
guérir d'une blessure parce qu'on aura
autour de lui une bulle de protection
qui sera embarquée donc on est quand
même assez loin de l'idée du Robocop et
on est certainement très loin de des
idées anxiogènes qui sont qui sont
aujourd'hui présentes dans la
littérature
[Musique]
parmi les projets phares soutenus par
l'agence de l'innovation de défense une
imprimante 3D capable de reconstruire le
derme et l'épiderme des grands brûlés
baptisé bloc print ce concept est
développé par un laboratoire civil et
financé par la Direction générale de
l'armement et le service de santé des
armées
cette nouvelle approche permettrait de
traiter en un temps record les brûlures
de la peau par impression 3D ce robot
fonctionne avec deux têtes la première
tête va scanner la zone brûlée
la taille de la zone à traiter pendant
ce temps un prélèvement d'une biopsie
est faite chez le patient ce prélèvement
est broyé et les micro fragments sont
mélangés avec une bio encre la deuxième
tête du robot va imprimer cette bio
encre cellularisée sur la zone à traiter
deux atouts majeurs dans ce procédé
d'abord c'est le délai avec la technique
classique le traitement par les
feuillets épidermiques entre le
prélèvement et la les premières greffes
il se passe 21 jours et là donc on voit
que le robot travaille dans le dès les
premières interventions chez le grand
brûlé et le deuxième grand atout c'est
le fait de pouvoir recréer à la fois le
derme qui est la résistance l'élasticité
de la peau et l'épiderme qui est la
barrière cutanée alors qu'avec les
feuillets épidermiques on ne fait que
cette barrière cutanée extérieure encore
au stade de l'expérimentation les
premiers résultats sont très prometteurs
un essai chez l'homme pourrait se
concrétiser dès 2021 prochaine étape
pour cette bio impression 3D la grève
d'organe un enjeu de taille en 2019 8000
patients restent dans l'attente d'une
greffe
sauver des vies mais aussi favoriser la
prise de décision du combattant c'est le
défi relevé par fast acronyme de
fantassins augmenter sécurisé tactique
ce casque doté de réalité augmentée
permet d'avoir directement dans son
champ de vision et en temps réel des
informations sur son environnement
il est doté de trois innovations
majeures la première c'est l'affichage
sur des écrans stéréoscopiques
binoculaires qui permet d'afficher des
informations à différentes distances
ainsi un point d'intérêt qui est à plus
de 100 mètres par exemple va être
affichée à l'infini la deuxième
innovation porte sur la notion de
communication le système permet de
communiquer de manière sécurisée au
système informatisé ce qui permet
également à chaque fantassin de savoir
où il est où et où sont ses collègues ce
qui évitent les tirs fratricides et
enfin chaque fantassin peut enrichir
lui-même cette situation tactique un peu
comme les applications sur smartphone
qui permettent de d'optimiser la
navigation en fonction du trafic chacun
va pouvoir mettre des unités qu'il a
qu'il a vu des ennemis des objets à
éviter des zones sécurisées de telle
manière à pouvoir partager et enrichir
cette situation de manière collaborative
et en temps réel et enfin la troisième
innovation porte sur le poste de
commandement qui accède à l'intégralité
de ces données peut également rajouter
de l'information en temps réel à sous
forme d'hologramme facile à comprendre
pour tous les fantassins sur le terrain
et également le poste de commandement
peut accéder au flux vidéo des caméras
qui sont déjà sur le sur les casques
intéressantes ou particulièrement les
Forces Spéciales cette innovation
pourrait les équiper d'ici à 2030
augmenter les capacités stratégiques des
combattants mais aussi mieux les
protéger et les sécuriser ça va bien
c'est l'objectif du projet hairshock
absorbeur un gilet balistique qui permet
d'amortir l'impact des balles ennemis
grâce à un système ingénieux
pour ce qui est du niveau de protection
balistique les combattants veut que les
choses qui protègent et donc forcément
ils veulent que quand un projet qu'il
arrive sur la protection le poids qu'il
soit arrêté c'est un peu ce qu'on voit
dans dans les films américains où les
gens sont tirés dessus ils tombent il
s'évanouit ils ont des gros bleu etc
mais il meurent pas parce qu'ils ont la
protection nous ce qu'on aimerait c'est
justement diminuer ses effets à
l'arrière de la protection tout en
protégeant le combattant
l'intérêt de la solution bancaire
développé par xProtect c'est d'apporter
donc un système d'amortissement à
l'arrière la protection parce que
effectivement pour diminuer ses effets
arrières la première chose auquel on
pense c'est d'éloigner la protection du
corps humain et à ce moment-là
effectivement il y a moins d'effets sur
le sur le sur le corps lors de l'impact
alors que là on arrive à en fait à
apporter un élément supplémentaire qui
est un élément d'amortissement sur le
lors de l'impact
et la toux c'est diminué les lésions
donc observer à l'arrière de la
protection balistique mais c'est
également de pouvoir diminuer le poids
de la protection balistique et donc si
on a un amortisseur spécifique qui pour
lequel on a réussi en fait à contenir le
poids on va pouvoir diminuer donc la
quantité de protection basique qui sont
eux relativement rares
[Musique]
ultra léger ce gilet balistique de
nouvelles génération est constituée de
coussins d'air
l'intérêt de d'utiliser l'air pour
absorber un choc c'est que vous générez
une déformation il y a une équation à
résoudre qui est que l'énergie arrive
pour dissiper une énergie on n'a pas
d'autres solutions que de déformer une
matière et l'aire A pour cette
problématique là était la plus adaptée
donc en gros on avait aujourd'hui une
mousse qui permettait d'écarter on est
bien d'accord que cette mousse n'a aucun
pouvoir à se déformer
alors que si on utilise l'air et
particulièrement de notre technologie
qui est dans de cloisonner l'air dans
des compartiments de façon à ce que
lorsqu'on va appuyer doucement l'air va
pouvoir circuler mais dès qu'on a un
choc violent
on absorbe on privit on a dans ce cas là
l'avantage d'avoir à la fois la gestion
de la déformation grâce à la pression ça
c'était une des premières problématiques
et du coup on a une vraie déformation
qui est organisée gérée par le volume
d'air dans chaque bulle par la petite
étude à la déplacer d'une bulle à
l'autre grâce à ses canaux et de là on
observe que on absorbe d'une manière
plus ou moins forte selon comment on
adapte ces réglages là l'énergie que la
balle va mener lors de son impact dans
le gilet par balle
au-delà de l'équipement du combattant
d'autres projets basés sur de
l'intelligence artificielle veulent
repenser la relation entre l'homme et la
machine
[Musique]
c'est l'exemple d'aspic qui s'inscrit
dans le projet Mad machine teamming
confié par la Direction générale de
l'armement à Dassault Aviation et à
Thalès
[Musique]
objectif aider un pilote dans sa prise
de décision
aujourd'hui il faut voir que l'émission
sont de plus en plus longues de plus en
plus complexes l'objectif principal
c'est aujourd'hui pour nous pour les
différents avions c'est de voir plus
loin de s'échanger davantage de données
donc de plus en plus connecté ce qui
fait qu'on a des flux d'information qui
arrivent dans tous les sens pour le
pilote et lui on va lui demander en plus
de prendre des décisions de plus en plus
rapidement donc pour cela on voit bien
que finalement les technologies comme
Léa vont être nécessaires dans le futur
parce que ces technologies là vont
permettre de digérer la donnée beaucoup
plus rapidement de fournir des premiers
éléments au pilote pour l'aider dans sa
prise de décision et le pilote va
pouvoir lui se concentrer davantage sur
les aspects statiques de la mission
l'anticipation l'analyse et la prise de
la décision notre objectif c'est que la
machine fournisse des éléments pour
aider le pilote dans la gestion de sa
mission mais la prise de décision ce
sera toujours le pilote qui va prendre
dans le cadre du projet aspic Dassault
Aviation arrive avec un besoin avec une
problématique technologique et crafty
fournit des solutions pour répondre à ce
besoin donc nous on arrive on explique
le contexte le cas d'application l'usage
et ensuite on va codévelopper cet
environnement va aider crafty récolter
des données et c'est crafts qui
travaillent sur l'algorithme et sur la
solution technologique qu'on veut mettre
en place
jeune start-up kraft à porte son
savoir-faire en matière d'intelligence
artificielle pour programmer le système
l'intelligence artificielle il faut voir
ça comme une formidable boîte à outils
de solutions et de technologie qui
permettent de répondre à des problèmes
complexes tels que l'analyse vidéo
l'analyse d'image l'analyse audio ou
comme dans ce cas l'aide à la prise de
décision
l'IA aujourd'hui elle peut résoudre
plein de problèmes différents comme ceux
que je viens de citer mais il y a encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire pour mettre
de l'IA en production et faire en sorte
qu'elle soit déployée dans des systèmes
complexes et on va pouvoir finalement
mettre notre caméra aujourd'hui on
utilise un simulateur de mission de type
RR qui va nous permettre de générer de
la donnée sur différents scénarios une
fois que ces données vont être générées
on va pouvoir créer des modèles qui vont
modéliser le comportement l'utilisation
de l'interface one machine du pilote de
l'utilisateur une fois ces modèles
générés on va pouvoir intégrer ces
modèles simulateur et faire en sorte que
ces modèles recommandent en temps réel
les bonnes pratiques à avoir
au cours de la mission
intelligence artificielle réalité
augmentée impression 3D toutes ces
innovations technologiques traduisent la
volonté de limiter l'engagement direct
des soldats et donc de réduire les
pertes humaines sur le champ de bataille
petit à petit les conflits changent de
visage
à l'avenir dans certaines situations
l'homme saura amené à s'appuyer sur
l'utilisation de robots pour l'aider
dans des missions de plus en plus
délicates ou l'hyper connectivité et la
réactivité prime mais l'utilisation de
machine pilotée par l'intelligence
artificielle est capable d'ouvrir le feu
soulève de nombreuses questions éthiques
la France a tranché pas question de
développer des robots qui agiraient de
façon pleinement autonome et échapperait
à tout contrôle humain
Terminator ne défilera pas au 14 juillet
la France a des valeurs
tout en embrassant les opportunités
fabuleuses qui sont offertes par
l'intelligence artificielle
des progrès technologiques doivent
rester au service des combattants
ce développement technologique vient à
créer des systèmes d'armes autonomes
donc des robots des robots soldats ce
robot il faudrait pas qu'il agisse seul
mais il faudrait qu'il agisse en
accompagnement de soldats humains que ce
soit comme un blindé qui est là en appui
et au sein d'une unité de soldats
humains qui combat et puis c'est un
appui supplémentaire
on voit partout la machine est fiable et
puis à l'obéit toujours le vrai problème
c'est que elle ne désobéit jamais
l'homme lui encore une fois il est
capable de discernement émotionnel il
est capable de prendre une décision par
lui-même en prenant en compte son
contexte et en prenant en compte son
vécu son expérience son ressenti de la
situation et parfois son instinct
également qui a une part quand même
assez importante au combat et il est
capable c'est presque paradoxal ce que
je vais dire mais il est capable de
désobéir et c'est là la différence
première avec la machine et c'est
peut-être là la plus grande force de
l'être humain
le combattant du futur bien sûr il sera
équipé d'énormément de technologie on
l'est déjà en au pilote dans les tigres
et dans les caïmans aujourd'hui ont de
la réalité augmentée devant les yeux
puisque sur la visière ils ont des
éléments qui s'affichent en
surimpression de leur vision du terrain
normal on est déjà dans un cadre ou nos
commentaires utilisent énormément de
technologie mais je suis persuadé que en
tout cas dans l'armée française l'homme
va rester au centre du combat et c'est
vraiment l'homme qui décidera depuis la
réflexion tactique jusqu'à la réflexion
sur le terrain sur jusqu'à la dernière
décision de d'ouverture du feu donc il
faut vraiment que on garde à l'esprit
cette place de l'être humain au cœur du
champ de bataille au cœur du combat et
qu'on garde à l'esprit la nécessité des
forces morales et donc de l'action du
collectif de la de la cohésion d'une
unité qui est la condition de la
victoire on pourra voir tous les outils
technologiques que l'on veut si on n'a
pas la force humaine et les forces
morales qui vont avec on pourra jamais
vendre
l'homme restera au cœur du combat c'est
fondamental en fait c'est c'est
l'essence même de la guerre la guerre
entre robot n'a pas de sens la guerre
c'est l'extrémité c'est la dernière
solution quand un état n'arrive plus par
la diplomatie à résoudre une difficulté
un problème donc la guerre est grave
elle doit le rester et étant grave elle
met en jeu la vie des hommes on l'a vu
le combat sera humain et il y a un
travail très important qui va être
réalisé et qui continuera d'être réalisé
c'est la préparation du combattant sa
préparation physique et aussi sa
préparation mentale c'est quelqu'un qui
doit porter des valeurs très fortes et
également des notions d'éthiques très
importantes pour mener l'action de la
République et de la France sur des
théâtres d'opérations extrêmement
complexes
[Applaudissements]
pour faire face aux questions
sous chaque jour la ministre des armées
a annoncé la création d'un comité
d'éthique sur les questions de défense
la France sera ainsi la première grande
puissance militaire à mettre en place
une structure de réflexion permanente
sur ces enjeux et se placera ainsi à la
pointe de la réflexion au niveau
international
[Musique]